In fact, the t-statistic I gave you is the one that we get when we do a
hypothesis test for the plane flight distance versus cost that we talked about
earlier. When we do linear regression in R, the statistical program that I've
briefly mentioned before, this is the output. Usually, you'll do software to do
any type of hypothesis test. Whether it's on a sample mean or two sample means
or the correlation coefficient or the slope, or whatever. The important thing
is that you understand the meaning of the software output. Here you see the t
value for this slope is pretty big, 5.77, the same value I gave you earlier,
and the p-value is pretty small. There are three stars by it, indicating that
the p-value is small enough to reject the null. Here are the significance
codes, which list the alpha levels. We see that three stars means we can reject
the null at the significance level of point 0.001. Since this slop is
significant, we know there's a true relationship between the distance traveled
and the cost of the ticket. Note that we can also conduct a hypothesis test on
the Y intercept, and in this case we see that's its not significant. The p
value is pretty high at 0.2 and there are no starts by it. This means that
we're not totally sure that the true intercept is at 161.38775. However, in
many cases, the estimate for the intercept is not of interest to researchers.
One reason is that this value could have no meaning in real life. Because x
equals 0 may not be realistic. For example, the price of iPods at the year zero
AD. iPods weren't even invented back then.